my mother always told me when you feel
bad or sad or have the ketchup song in
your head just play roller coaster
tycoon 3 and you don't need to worry so
that's what we're going to do today
we're going to play roller coaster
tycoon 3 with me sovereign and I'm going
to teach you how to do boring stuff like
photos and flanges because nobody ever
ever ever likes doing photos and flange
is that the most boring process of the
entire thing it's just it's hard to
screw this up as well it's just anybody
can do this but it's really is really
boring doesn't really require any
thoughts or any creativity or any
somehow brain stimulating processes it's
just really boring so photos is just
yeah I
when you're building a BM like I am
right now always use CP cisco's bnm
photos not and nothing else may be aged
photos if you feel like that if you're
trying to get an old looki kind of rusty
kind of coaster but in any other
scenario don't do it just just use this
because it's the most realistic and best
tip that is of course if you don't want
to be realistic or do something cool
like this that of course you you're free
to use whatever but I just recommend
using this one but yeah just just place
these things and for example if you've
got something like this going on on a
corner piece then the best way to go is
use an edge corner piece which usually
fits really well like that so for this I
would normally since these are diagonal
supports also use some diagonal photos
so I'm going to take the you know what
I'll actually explain a little about the
placement of these photos so we've got
the corner piece which goes on these
corners so basically where that blue
things cross always always turn on the
grid especially when you're doing photos
and flanges but the corner pieces are on
the grid slash in the middle of a square
the center pieces are actually not
really in the center of a piece but in
the center of a quarter of a piece of a
square in the grid so that means that
little in that little corner be
twin two corner pieces basically now the
edge pieces are on these lines but on
the site so they're like center pieces
but on the lines of the grid and then
all of the combination ones are just a
combination between them so for example
a when like four X I'll give an example
yeah I'll totally do that so we've got a
corner piece right here we've got a
center piece here and I mean another
corner piece here then of course there
should be a center piece in the middle
right here so a centipede never mind
so we're going to take a cent center
piece and look it's exactly in the
middle but if you want for example a
piece s in between these pieces then you
can take a center corner piece which
will end up in the middle of these
pieces or if you turn it around in the
middle of these pieces that's basically
how all of the placements work if you
didn't know that yet it's really
important if you want to do the footer
placement fast and the right way so for
this for example this thing seems to be
a center piece but a center piece will
just miss it like you see right here so
it's probably going to have to be a
Center corner piece because it's kind of
in between the center and the corner so
let's see and yes it is indeed a Center
corner piece so yeah I always see many
people complaining about the how this
others kind of photo system works
because there's so many placements and
it can be really annoying but as you can
see if you just just kind of mess around
with it a little and try to memorize
more all of the placements or that it's
a lot easier to work around with this so
this seems to be a centerpiece slash
Center corner piece I'll just have to
see what looks best it does appear to be
sent a corner piece so I'll try that and
yeah that's pretty much of a perfect fit
right there so then this should be one -
yup and then this is probably a center
piece let's see Center well yeah that's
that's actually really good the only
thing is that it's sticking out here we
don't want that
going to have to change the support on
it then in this in this kind of a case I
would normally just remove the extended
support because extended supports are
actually good for nothing supports the
only thing that they're good for is
saving time but in a case like this when
you've got terraforming and supports
like and footers like these it's best to
not oh god I totally forgot about that
let's see you know what forget about
that in a case like this you can always
just take a bush later on or a rock and
cover that little thing up so we're just
going to skip it now don't care about
little details like that that can bother
you just forget about your OCD for a
moment annual and just place a little
shrub right there later on something
like that something that covers it up so
moving on we've got some straight
supports again here so that means we're
going to use some straights footers so
let's see some some corner pieces I'm
totally blind right now now this never
make it intersect with the terraforming
like this by the way that's really
annoying and if it intersects with a
connector like that I'd usually change
it to the color of the connector like
this and by the way when placing
supports I would always keep a minimum
height of the footer I mean yeah I mean
when placing photos actually I always
want to keep a minimum height of the
footer of just that little edge so that
you can still see the edge of the footer
and it doesn't sink into the terrain
because I I just don't like it when I
see that it doesn't really make sense
either now this isn't quite perfect for
an HP so you can take a corner hp's an
edge corner and that's what they're
called and that's a perfect fit so
basically there is no single situation
in which there's not a perfect photo for
this which is pretty cool these photos
always end up working no matter what
kind of weird support it is the only
thing that I sometimes have problems
with is tarah for
because that can sometimes lead to some
weird situations where your supports are
going into a rock or something and it's
really hard to add a good footer to it
but in almost every case these photos
really work in contrary with some
footage which only have these corner
placements for example and then it's a
lot harder to get some good for the
placements now let's see I'm totally
missing the corner pick oh wait I need a
centerpiece totally forgot about that no
I don't need a centerpiece
I need a center corner piece good
alright that's all looking great
no I'm not sure what I need here Center
corner piece I guess yeah good enough as
long as well this is something that I
like to think of as long as the support
doesn't hit one of these bulbs you're
safe basically although this might
change if you've got one H supports that
you want to add a footer to but in any
case you should never have any one H
support leaning onto the ground not in
any scenario because that belly supports
anything now I need some edge pieces for
this of course so wait oh we thought I
was missing something
there's a bit of close to the ground but
not too close so I'll just do it by the
way I did get a message from someone who
was totally right there is a set called
steel chaos which is yeah which is a
satin which has the pieces Mobe steel
jungle has plus a lot more
it but it's got like hundreds of pieces
and some people like to use it but I
don't like to use it because it's not
exactly user-friendly and it really
messes up my custom scenery list and
it's a set that consists out of multiple
other sets so and also sometimes stands
to generate some extra lag so I don't
like it due to that but if you want you
can get that
because it has some pieces that mobi
steel jungle doesn't have like the
infamous 6h piece that I always want to
complain about so if you want to use
that set and call me a hypocrite then
you can go ahead I'll put a link to it
in the description if I don't forget
about that if I do forget about that you
can of course leave your comments and
say hey silver at where the [ __ ] is
where the [ __ ] is si okay just give it
to me and I'll post a link to it of
course now I'm having some trouble with
this support right here it's not really
the best support you can have but this
is close enough not hitting any of the
bolts should be good enough now yes
supporting does tend to be a little bit
boring
I mean placing footers I keep saying
supporting why does that even happen but
yeah this is this is kind of a boring
job and sorry for not cutting out any of
this but like I said I I wanted this to
be a full tutorial as in my entire
stream of thoughts and every single
thoughts on every single thing in the
game uncut and raw so that that is this
so if you really want to learn something
from minami then I I guess you could
listen to me in the background while
doing something useful with your life
but that seems like a good idea to me
again this is a bit of a weird placement
so each corner is a way to go looks good
not hitting any of the bolts and some
normal corner pieces again I'm always
glad when I see these corner pieces
because you know you don't really have
to mess with it it's easy placement you
don't have to deal with any of those
weird edge your center pieces it's just
just nice and easy a right here I'm
going to have to mess with these edge
pieces again so don't like it when that
happens
this is an edge corner and this is an
edge born as well
okay last great now let's see hmm
wait some people complain about the
corkscrew supports one I don't quite
remember what it was oh I think oh yeah
was something about that you had to
support the top of the corkscrew but
that doesn't happen not with roller
coaster tycoon I not with B&M coasters
bnm coasters don't have supports on the
top of it that's just not how they roll
except a corkscrew is not really a roll
only in line twists and barrel rolls or
rolls though but I'd say they still kind
of roll in a way I mean it's kind of a
roll rolling motion but anyway they they
just don't have those arches of supports
above them which support them from the
top just doesn't happen they support it
from the sides though there might be
some being on coasters which have
supports like that and and yes I do feel
like these supports are really low but
that they're decent they're good enough
the truck is not that heavy plus it's
not a narrow coaster where it's that
terrible that they have to put supports
and cat water everywhere
I mean being um knows what they're doing
that one of that one of the one of the
most uh most best yet one of their
favorite roller coaster creator
companies kind of whatever you call
those things apparently apparently they
are really good at building roller
coasters don't ask me I'm not I'm not
actually not really a coaster
enthusiasts I just know about all those
business do to this game but other than
that I couldn't care less about roller
coasters sorry guys I do like the way
they look I'm not I'm not one guy who
goes to theme park and then instead of
actually riding the roller coasters he
just looks at them going mmm that's
beautiful and I get my aesthetic
contemplation going so that's me
yeah I said it I've said it multiple
times in private Skype calls from Lee
but not now you guys know it too I'm not
a coaster enthusiasts just just go away
we're going stupid coasters
you know coasters are cool and all but
it's not not not [ __ ] life okay I do
visit the theme park review theme book
yeah
basically because every time every time
I can't I post a comment on on that
channel like every time I post a comment
on one of the videos they're like some
people have to say oh my god it is
silver rats and then I get all the
thumbs up and then that's so [ __ ]
funny I just can't stop even though I've
been on even though I've been on TPR for
like three years probably I've always
watch many of their videos but just
every time I leave your comments I don't
know people recognize me which is kind
of cool in a way but also maybe a bit
annoying if I if I'm on a video and I
see somebody commenting and then I see
people going oh my god it's him and then
a flood people it's kind of kind of a
kind of weird and it's kind of what are
you doing but then again it's a comment
section who really gives a [ __ ] you know
it's uncensored you can do whatever you
want except yeah these days you can do
whatever you want oh these supports are
really awkward yeah I've also heard
people say that yes you might want to
place the support in the middle right
there and I figured no because this is a
very small Cobra role and small Cobra
roles don't always have three supports
but if I look at it from the side it
does look a bit Oh does look a bit weird
but oh I'll do that when I get to an
episode where I just do the finishing
touches on the coaster itself before
moving on to the scenery of course
because if anything if anything by the
way before you move on to see doing the
scenery you want to have everything in a
coaster finished because you know you
want to built the the scenery around the
coast and not the other way around
around around around around
forget about that mainly because you
don't want the coastal layout to be all
weird and wibbly-wobbly just because you
need to move around scenery that is of
course only if you're not making scenery
that is actually part of the
rollercoaster like some people add
buildings that support the
roller-coaster in one way or another or
they or the scenery is actually the
supports or the supports are actually
the scenery or whatever you like to say
about that then in that kind of case
then yes you should come up with the
order of yourself but if you're making a
generic coaster then you should always
do the supports first and then the
scenery in the foliage just because you
don't want to create any collisions or
awkward supports or awkward layouts just
to move around things scenery is the
most flexible thing thing you can build
in roller coaster country you can easily
build it around stuff and it's not
that's not really the case with coaster
layouts or supports that's kind of why
you need to pay attention to that and by
the way you can see that I'm replacing
vertical flanges on these angled pieces
you should never do that only if you're
lazy like I am I'll just you know what
I'll just add a slanted flange right
here it doesn't really make that much of
a difference you can only you can only
see the difference if you look from up
closely but if you if you're looking
from a distance you can barely see those
flanges anyway so it doesn't really
matter that much if you're in a board
mood by the way and you don't want to
deal with all these flanges just just
only use vertical flanges don't bother
with the horizontal or angled flanges or
anything like that just notice that I
forgot doing the photos for these
corkscrew supports we'll do that right
away by the way if you've got multiple
supports are exactly the same like I do
here just use control to get the flange
everywhere in the same spot let's see
just notice that this support is off oh
wow that is a that's a fill my part well
we'll fix that as well and let's see
what else
you know what um yeah this is this is
good enough don't need any other flanges
you don't need to place flanges on small
supports they don't really exist so
multiple tubes by the way just some
history for for anyone if you don't know
that yet flanges other things that are
used to connect these beams to each
other so that you can make support now
of course in rollercoaster tycoon 3 we
have mobile steel jungle and no gravity
so we don't need flanges but for realism
purposes some people like to place them
and I do of course too because like I
probably sent at some point earlier but
I'm not sure if I also did it in this
video I probably did but if you do not
place down flanges everyone's going to
be bothered and complain about it and
whine about it but if you do place them
nobody even gives a [ __ ] so it's that
kind of annoying thing it's that thing
which you have to do but nobody actually
cares about except those with OCD but
those would OCD can can can go away
let's see Oh God
the the awkward placements again oh this
is good enough because otherwise it's
intersecting with the terraforming now I
should have had everything at this point
which I do yeah so I'm almost finished
for that for today that's that's great
and now I can finish this video off and
render it and upload it tomorrow or
something which is quite cool I'm
actually I'm actually not really pre
recording these videos most of my other
videos are mostly pre recording like my
let's play videos are most of all pre
recorded sometimes they're months old
before I upload them I just booked
create them but these are the kinds of
videos that I can create relatively fast
so these are the kinds of videos that
are actually quite new when I upload
them because today it's like the 3rd of
June I guess yeah so
hi guys I am NOT from the past I am from
from from the now I'm from the now maybe
I am from the future
wait no that's that's impossible oh
let's see now this should be good enough
but it isn't so I'm going to have to
replace that support as well because
this is kind of weird
let's see mobi steel jungle where you
are where you win well mo calm sorry
where you at wombo combo plus one for
anyone who recognizes that reference by
the way speaking of wombo combo I've got
a montage parody coaster coming up for
all of you sorry this is not an update
video but I just want to say to all of
you who are watching right now and are
still watching in the past and not in
the future when I've already finished
and uploaded that Monteverdi coaster
remember about my three thousand subs
video within which I said you guys come
up with the theme posted and the comment
with them with the biggest amount of
thumbs up will actually be the theme for
the next coaster yeah it's going to be a
montage parody coaster so if you don't
know what that is you have the time to
to look it up and see what it is and be
like why you're even doing this I don't
even know but yeah I promised that I do
the coaster so yeah I'm going to have
I'm going to have to build that
Monteverdi coaster I'm pretty much
forced to because it's pretty much my
promise but that was today's episode
thank you for watching and yeah I'll see
you next episode in which I do yeah well
what am I going to do next episode I
figure I'm just just going to do the
catwalks finish the whatever I to finish
probably the third support right there
and start working the Q line I guess I'm
finished the station because I still
need to finish that so till then
by travelpod member